je vais vous parler d'une rencontre une
rencontre avec un être chevelu un être
beau comme un astre c'est une rencontre
très particulière puisque c'est une
comète
donc cette rencontre commence toujours
par un éblouissement cet éblouissement
c'est ce petit point en ciel qui tout
d'un coup devient une comète c'est à
dire une activité c'est à dire quelque
chose qui répand du gaz répand des
poussières
mais qu'est ce que sont les comètes
alors dans l'histoire les comètes
étaient des désastres qui annonçait des
catastrophes sur des champs de bataille
c'était synonyme de défaite mais quand
on réfléchit bien il y avait quand même
les perdants mais il y avait aussi les
gagnants donc pour les gagnants la
comète était synonyme de victoire donc
on pouvait leur faire dire n'importe
quoi mais les comètes c'est l'objet qui
vous donne le spectacle le plus sublime
dans le ciel et je vais vous donner un
exemple c'est celui-là ça s'est passé en
2007 ont malheureusement c'est
l'hémisphère sud donc on n'a pas vu ici
mais voilà ce que peut donner une comète
dans le ciel c'est quelque chose qui est
extraordinaire et que je vous invite à
voir si si une passe prochainement alors
qu'est ce que sont les comètes ce sont
des petits objets mais qui peuvent avoir
une très longue queue très longue c'est
presque la distance de la terre au
soleil donc c'est vraiment gigantesque
en l'occurrence deux que vous voyez à
une que bleu c'est une queue de d'atomes
ionisé c'est que lumineuse et pink
blanche cd queue de poussière qui
réfléchit par le soleil et puis dans
cette boule un peu un peu curieuse au
milieu vous avez quelque chose qu'on ne
voit pas c'est le noyau
alors qu'est ce qu'un noyau de comètes
en fait on en connaît très peu des
noyaux de comètes
je vous en présente cinq on n'en connaît
pas pas un de plus donc ces décors un
peu une forme de cacahuète
tout ce que vous voulez le plus célèbre
c'est le noyau de la comète de halley
parce que en 1986 l'europe avec giteau
les russes avec vega sont allés survolé
cette comète la plus célèbre du monde
et on a vu ce noyau que vous voyez ici
avec ces j'ai déjà et ça nous a donné
l'idée de dalles et d'aller faire cette
rencontre alors la comète de halley sur
cette image vous voyez elle elle revient
tous les 75 ans et pourtant elle va déjà
jusqu'à l'orbité de neptune et pluton
mais il y en a d'autres que vous ne
connaissez pas notamment il ya coutach
et kate une comète qui est venu nous
voir et quelques années et celle là elle
va pas revenir dans son temps pendant
mille ans pas dans dix mille ans dans
cent mille ans donc voyez les comètes
sont très rares et donc elles vivent au
congélateur
elles sont très très loin du soleil et
comme vous savez quand vous mettez les
aliments au congélateur voulait
conserver longtemps des mois et des mois
ici on les conserve quatre milliards et
demi d'années donc le matériau des
comètes n'a pas bougé depuis la
formation du système solaire c'est à
dire le soleil les planètes les comètes
et les astéroïdes tout ce qui tourne
autour du soleil tout ça à peu près 4 5
milliards d'années
et dans le cas des comètes ça n'a pas
bougé c'est pour ça qu'on est très
intéressé par l'étude de ces objets
alors maintenant je vous la présente et
ça a été vraiment une surprise
on a vu deux objets dans le collet d'un
à l'autre on s'est dit qu'est ce que
c'est que cette histoire c'est ma fille
m'a dit tiens c'est un pied de hobbit et
c'est vrai que ça ressemblait un pied de
hobbits vu de loin bien sûr de presse
ana plus tout à fait cette tête et après
on a appelé un canard avec la tête le
corps et tout ça ça ressemble un fruit à
peu flétri une laisse et une laisse et
une pomme un mois dans votre placard ça
va donner à peu près une comme étant sa
personne et la comète c'est pareil parce
que les comètes sont extrêmement riches
en glace d'eau et donc l'activité des
comètes cette perte son nom le voilà ce
noyau
il est c'est un fruit flétrie il fait
environ 4 kg matière qu'il a la taille
d'une montagne c'est plus petit que le
mont blanc et est néanmoins c'est un
objet qui sur lequel on a envie de faire
beaucoup de choses qui qu'on va étudier
alors pour l'étudier il a fallu se
rencontrer et pour rencontrer il a fallu
fabriquer nous un engin c'est celui-là
c'est rosetta en
au clin d'oeil avec la pierre de rosette
qui a permit de déchiffrer les
hiéroglyphes
nous on va déchiffrer l'histoire du
système solaire comment il s'est formé
il ya 4,5 milliards d'années
c'est un engin gigantesque qui fait 3
tonnes le gros cube fait trois mètres à
peu près et les panneaux solaires sont
plus grands que cette scène ils font 32
mètres parce qu'on va très très loin du
soleil on va au niveau de jupiter et il
a fallu dix ans pour fabriquer ces temps
cet engin parce qu'on n'est pas très
rapide dans le spatial faut bien dire
c'est compliqué mais en plus il a fallu
dix ans pour aller voir la comète c'est
la trajectoire blanche vous voyez ici on
a fait quatre tours autour du soleil
la grande trajectoire du bas c'est
jupiter donc on a frôlé presque jupiter
et le petit point blanc c'est là où nous
sommes aujourd'hui à l'heure où je vous
parle on est en train de se voir et le
rendez vous a eu lieu alors on l'a fait
et ben on a fait ce que vous faites
souvent on a fait un selphy et voilà
vous avez un beau selphy de la comète
un panneau solaire vue par la tranche ça
fait un peut espérer industriels pour
ceux qui s'intéressent au sujet est
derrière la comète toujours avec c'est
son petit corps et son ce petit tesson
gros corps est l'objet de rose est assez
étudié l'activité l'émergence de
l'activité on a voulu retrouver la
comète loin du soleil et elle va
commencer à être active
elle est active aujourd'hui voilà
l'activité de la comète on voit des jets
qui partent justement entre la tête et
le corps c'est là où ses actifs et les
gaz on les voit pas mais les gars
s'entraînent des poussières etc ces
poussières que l'on voit ici en fait la
totalité de la comète est active et ça
va aller de mal en pis et nous on va
rester autour pendant un an et demi et
on espère qu'on va pas se prendre des
gros blocs parce que parfois il ya des
gros blocs qui se promènent gros comme
des ballons de basket et donc on va
faire très attention se rapproche
doucement de la comète et mois des liens
en plein d'instruments
alors je vais pas vous les listes et
parce que l'on y passerez une heure mais
on va étudier le noyau on va étudier des
grains on va étudier le gaz on va on va
se le regarder dans le visible dans
l'infrarouge toutes les longueurs d'onde
on a même un radar parce qu'on veut
connaître l'intérieur de la comète
donc on va faire tout ça mais ça c'est
pas suffisant on a envie de faire
quelque chose d'un peu plus compliqué et
on a envie de lui de lui faire un bisou
de lui donner un kiss
et on a fabriqué un drôle d'engin qui
est là on a appelé fils a alors filé
vous connaissez pas mais c'est une
obélisque a servi un petit peu jean
françois champollion de décrypter les
hiéroglyphes aussi donc fille là et
c'est un engin qui fait à peu près un
mètre vingt mètres cubes sur trois pieds
et on va le larguer et il va se poser
sur la comète
je vous donne rendez vous le 12 novembre
à 16h35
on doit se poser mais pour se poser il
faut trouver un endroit pour se poser et
or la comète depuis depuis le fin
juillet on la connaissait pas donc on a
commencé à la regarder de partout et
regardez moi cette cette chose
comment voulez vous vous posez là dessus
on se croirait sur une montagne plainte
de granit
on voit des blocs alors chaque point de
l'image c'est un terme que vous
comprendrez facilement fait un mètre
donc les blocs que vous voyez ici ils
font dix mètres donc on peut se tombait
sur un immeuble
on a l'impression qu'ici que les blocs
sont suspendus dans le vide mais en fait
télé ou la verticale elle n'est pas
forcément là où l'on croit le blog qu'il
n'est pas il n'est pas en train de
tomber il est simplement à l'horizontale
là où il est et et la gravité est très
faible
on a cherché et puis finalement la
trouver on a trouvé le meilleur endroit
pour se poser et je peux vous dire qu'il
n'est pas terrible cet endroit c'est sur
la croix rouge
mais on a encore des blocs qui font dix
mètres
on a des falaises qui font 60 mètre
soixante degrés pardon et 60 degrés pour
nous c'est pas bon on va pas se poser
sur une falaise de 60 degrés on va on va
tourneboulé donc ma vaille que vaille
on espère que ça va marcher on a une
chance d'avoir un succès ou un échec
on verra rendez vous le 12 novembre
alors comment ça va se passer là on a
mis une caméra imaginez une caméra sur
un nom ma qui n'existe pas et qui fixe
par rapport à filer c'est la comète qui
se rapproche en fait c'est nous qui nous
rapprochons de la comète et tout d'un
coup on va larguer fils a et 1 la
seconde près dans une position voilà le
largage a eu lieu et là on va me
descendre pendant sept heures et phil
hay et bouge pas parce qu'évidemment on
a mis la caméra fixe et c'est la comète
qui arrive la comète tournant 12h sur
elle même c'est un monstre c'est une
montagne et nous on descend vaille que
vaille très lentement
on va se poser trois kilomètres heure
donc tout est très lent retour d'une
comète que la gravité très faible on a
cette fameuse ellipses où c'est là
dedans qu'on va se poser ce point rouge
c'est là qu'on espère qu'on sera aimé on
sait que à cause de divers paramètres on
va se poser quelque part sur l'hélice
l'ellipse et voilà on atterrit et ça
c'est 16h35 le 12 novembre et
l'atterrissage alors là c'est la partie
la plus la plus angoissante la plus
difficile notre engin fait 100 kg ici et
quand il va être posé sur la comète il
va peser deux grammes
alors comment on fait déjà dès qu'on se
pose on plaque au sol donc on a une
espèce de fusées vous voyez pas ici qui
va plaquer pile au moment du contact et
au moment où on sera au sol les deux
petites pointes en dessous ce sont des
harpons donc on va tirer de harpon deux
parce que un c'est deux c'est mieux que
rien si un vainqueur au rabais ya le
deuxième on espère bien qu'il y en a un
qui va qui va s'accrocher après autant
les câbles et on devrait ancrer ça c'est
la théorie
rendez vous le 12 novembre si tout
marche bien alors après dès qu'on est
posé vous inquiétez pas la comète ça
absolument pas la tête que ça sur cette
image on sait pas du tout quelles têtes
ça une comète de vue depuis le sol c'est
la première chose qu'on va faire on va
faire un panorama on va faire un 360
degrés et on va tout de suite envoyé sa
vers la terre parce que tout le monde
veut voir ce panorama et nous nous
travaillons sur ce projet moi qui
travaille depuis vingt ans j'aimerais
bien savoir si on est posée est la
meilleure preuve pour qu'on soit posée
c'est de voir le panorama alors après on
va faire de la science bien sûr on est
là pour ça c'est l'objectif de cette
mission
on va utiliser ce radar dont je vous ai
parlé et ce radar ça va consister à
envoyer une onde par fille rose et a
filé va recevoir londe et on va passer à
travers noyau faire des coupes
si on trouve que le noyau est très
homogène on pourra dire que tout ça il
ya 4,5 milliards d'années
ça c'est au clos maire et lentement
doucement si par contre on trouve des
gros blocs de 10 m 200 m on pourra dire
que oui ça s'est agglomérée meyboom il
ya eu des méchants contact il ya eu des
la comète s'est brisé et puis ensuite
tout ça tourneboulé ça sert et
agglomérés et on pense que c'est
probablement ça qu'on va trouver c'est à
dire qu'il ya eu dvd des événements très
violent et c'est l'objet de ces mesures
radar mais le plus important c'est ce
qu'on va faire après ce qu'on va faire
après c'est qu'on va forer sur la comète
on va forer avec cette foreuse et puis
au bout on prend un échantillon pourquoi
parce que la comète c
ce sont les corps les plus riches en
glace et quand la comète se rapproche du
soleil mais évidemment ça fait une
cocotte minute et ça sort par des jets
ça emmène des poussières alors les
poussières nous intéresse beaucoup
parce que les comètes sont les corps les
plus riches en carbone et ses carbone on
a déjà 25 molécules détectées depuis le
sol
mais le matériau qui est très sombre qui
est peut-être aussi noir que du charbon
on le connaît pas et donc cette analyse
avec cette foreuse c'est le but c'est de
2,2 d'analyser ce carbone qui est
probablement très complexe on l'a
comparé sa de la suie et finalement on a
dû carbone
on l'a de l'eau et l'écho bête c'est
quand même des objets on le sait ça
bombarde et la terre ça bombarde et la
terre il ya 4 milliards d'années et
c'est l'eau est arrivée dans les océans
le carbone est arrivé dans les océans
puis le carbone est arrivé dans l'eau et
vous savez quand on arrive dans l'eau
l'océan est bien chaud à cette époque
tous à sa folie molécules complexes a
fait des des membranes ça fait des
cellules
ça fait la vie donc pour conclure
finalement ce qui nous intéresse dans
cette cette histoire absolument
exceptionnel d'atterrissage sur une
comète c'est comprendre nos origines
nous on veut comprendre le système
solaire comment il s'est formé mais on
veut aussi comprendre comment la vie est
apparue à partir de ce carbone cométaire
à partir de cet os donc je vous donne
rendez vous le 12 novembre à ses heureux
dit merci